right but a lot of people like to
dictate that ben chang is serious when
he goes claudio right
and i want to see if the matchup kind of
makes him go a different way or will we
just get the claudio right out of the
gate
i mean we'll see i mean he's gonna have
his work cut out for him we know he you
know we know that he's a beast you know
bing chang has always been a beast he's
being able to play
at the highest level and really you know
take on all comers but you know
this longer set now in the winter's
finals we're gonna have a three out of
five right so there is going to be some
time to adjust here he picks claudia he
has picked players i told you that's how
he knows the business is going
my gosh it is definitely the busiest
time and it's claudio
going up against paul joey fury's paul
going up against the claudio yeah it's
been so long and he got the cowboy paul
you know what that means
demoman's death fists and damage let's
go
oh man the 3ds you got to watch out
three ds baby
oh right now joey fury is definitely
putting hands on benching that was a
very quick first round
yeah that was real quick i told you man
demomans the second
death fist and damage the last d of the
three
oh look at the dance on the wall
mr joey fury the fury i like to call it
i don't know if he gets embarrassed if i
call him that in public if i see him
walking down the street on the other
side i'm like yo the fury i'ma just yell
it across the street
he he emanates it out there's his aura
you could tell he's the viewer
because he's so calm big damn you go
what are you gonna do bing chang had the
nice positioning there this time getting
the swipe
oh my god oh still spinning
rims still spinning
good movement
i feel like paul is definitely uh what
really gets people nice duck and
punished
those he has a pretty far reaching
special moves that can kind of open
people up
makes that death fist a little more
scary uh demo man as well
nice side step four right there to get
that big hit and now joey fury trying to
fight his way back into this round 35
seconds left on the clock
looking forward down 4-2 spins the blue
hop kick
oh gonna get the wall for sure this he
might be dead yeah he's dead
two rounds to one in his first to three
sidewalk tries to go for this down four
two down back three finds his mark
the spacing so far enjoy playing
uh pretty far back right now so is ben
chang
oh man gets to meet it pinching is
really starting to put control in the
matchup here joey fury's gonna have to
figure out a way to get in
this isn't their first time running into
each other either man we've seen these
guys play in icfc superman goes for the
low
didn't adjust no block first game three
rounds to one
will go to infinites ben chang the
claudio came out to play what did i say
sometimes you got to pop the trunk
instantly you can't be out here playing
around
okay joy fury is a monster that's what
happens when you want to win you go
straight to the business you just you
know what
hey mom i need my business suit put it
in the suitcase
and get ready for action baby oh yeah
well
there's uh a lot to be said there i mean
looking into this again there it's a
race to three
it's not as a shorter set than we're
used to so
i feel like there's going to be some
adjustments coming and you know both of
these players we know
they use multiple characters they can
use them at the highest level to win
tournaments
so i wouldn't be surprised i would not
be surprised if we see any character
switches going into it
well i'm interested to see i feel like
that did not work out i feel like uh
the getting the game started versus that
claudio
was almost impossible and we know like
paul's really good at
opening people up because they get
afraid of those pokes but i talked about
the distance that was being played by
both of them
even with some of those long reaching
special moves from paul those long
reaching uh moves that can't get to you
claudio wasn't even he was like ben chad
was like i'm not gonna even give you an
opportunity i'm just gonna play at this
range to where
if you come in i'm gonna do something
get an adjustment make you straighten
out and play from there
and i feel like we might actually we
might see a character switch from joey
three now that i said that out loud and
i kind of like put some thought to it
i'm pretty sure we're gonna see a
character switch from joy fury
you know what he's been using marduk so
much in a lot of tournaments
and he's been had seen so much success
with him i i feel like martin's coming
out i feel like the tackles are coming
um the tackles are coming out and play
the grounder pound
might be in the game right now well
we're about to see
next battle like we said this is first
to three on the winner's side to see
who's going to get to this grand finals
someone's going to go to that loser's
side and have to play a couple more
matches the marduk is coming out no you
sure right man there it is
so claudio going up against marta joy
fury with the switch
and i feel like now we're going to see a
little more offense
from joy fury he's going to try to find
these openings to make ben chang come
out of that shell a little bit game
number two and his winners finally
oh yeah completely different approach
when you're going up against martic here
uh because he has certain tools like the
tackle he has you know the ability to
go into different throws and not only
that he has some killer okie
post juggle as well so here we go we're
at the wall let's see what binch is able
to do here goes for the flip over
oh the trooper roll round
[Music]
two
dancing a little bit ben chang's still
in the lead
takes that first round pretty
convincingly quick side step gets him
out of the way
that uh down back three oh superman
punch
do it again he got up at the last second
yeah look he tried to do like a fuzzy
duck right there and he's just reading
it they're running too
okay delay this time a punish here from
bing chang what's he gonna do
closes it out with the low series
dang this is a quick work here bing
chang putting joey fury into a very
uncomfortable position now
oh counter hit man i love that stagger
animation can get the wall of play
properly
oh he did get the wall sidewall stun
though kind of messes up the potential
damage there
you actually get a couple of tech
options once they hit the wall because
they uh take the other way if they quick
take off the wall
wait a minute and as we say this joy
fury takes this other round back but we
saw this in that last game
it was 3-1 when it came to the side of
ben chang
get off of me hands off the suit i gotta
go to work after this oh yeah that
casino ain't gonna protect itself
dry clean only baby uh-huh what's he
gonna do what's he gonna do
he's waiting he's just dashing in
waiting for a reaction here from bin
chang
oh you tucked and he plucked it i can't
believe you blocked that
okay and this is what i was talking
about playing back there's that tackle
you were talking about
ready with the break still gets a little
bit of damage he staggers into that down
4-1
that bad boy's got some range looking
for the wall nothing doing oh my god he
actually kicked him out of the hopkins
wall splat he's not dead still gets the
4-3 to get the tail spin
what's he gonna do he's gonna have to be
very careful here he does have starburst
starburst against rage
again that's the second time that he's
done that to close out the match it's
going to be 2-0
on the side of ben chang and i honestly
think we might see another character
switch i think we're going to see
another character switch i mean who else
is he going to use
is he going to go back to paul i think
he might go to jail what if he goes to
jack i think he might do a lot better
with jack honestly and i'm going to tell
you why i think the fact that
ben chang is playing very far back he is
not letting joey fury get any game
started
if you notice we saw him play joey fury
played with marduk earlier he gauged you
and then he was like you know what i'm
gonna hit you with this down four
the only thing that he didn't get in
this set was the fact that he wasn't
getting those pokes the reason he wasn't
getting those pokes it was because ben
chang was playing a lot further back uh
with punishing with claudio is a lot
more powerful i feel like because you
get that hop kick you're gonna get that
launch
not so much uh on the side of marduk
marduk has to get in he has to
make you uh make a mistake he has to
make you duck and i felt
like that's why you switched to marta
you like you know what let me see if i
can force them to get a little antsy
they don't want to get hit by my tackle
i still have down four one i got counter
hit push i got down four i have stuff to
make them
you know antsy but ben chang didn't bite
so now we're back at square one
it's two games to none and i feel like
we're going to see a character switch
from joey fury
well it's going to be interesting to see
which character he does pick uh
stacy steve you think he's going to
switch uh he has a number of characters
i know he's been messing around with
gandhi you a lot
he's but the thing is when he does
switch these characters now if he does
switch a character
he's stuck with that character and he
has to win with that character three
matches in a row if he wants to make it
to grand finals he can win with jack bro
if he's if he's accidental that's the
secret lab jack i feel like he can do it
but he might stick with the motor i told
you oh man
as soon as i said i was like ah but if i
stick with the bardock ah
i was hoping we were gonna see a
character switch i would love to see him
pull the paw
back out but i mean not the paul but uh
the jack back up but here we go
sticking to his guns the casino outfit
is the one
okay
yeah bing chang's just really been
controlling the flow of the matchup
and see the thing joey's been doing too
he's been dashing in waiting for a
reaction from bin chang bin shang hasn't
been biting at all
yeah bing chang has been calm collected
so far
and now you see those pokes starting to
add up a little more getting a couple of
hits but the life lead is still in ben
chang's favor he's willing to take those
pokes and tries to get out of there
it's a down 4-1 on the back dash once
again
goes for a quick vel tudo option
not dead but this is going to be a
situation really close to that wall and
nice go straight for the mid that was
good
round two fight
counting down four two no
wall trooper roll wow didn't hit him
he's a big boy
he took the thought right out of my head
yo
what you gonna do goes for the down
forward one he's a jack player
there's that down four i think joey
fury's back to the wall really helps him
out in his match-up
yeah i mean there's a lot of ways where
you can switch positions as well too and
i wouldn't be surprised if we see him go
for it whether it's a normal grab
or what but there's a big opportunity oh
my gosh he's so good with that running
too
he is so good with that the minute you
want to start moving around he's going
to test you he has no problem being like
oh
you feel like you can move around now
eat these superman punches hold up hold
these
you gotta duck i'm gonna make you commit
to it one round of peace in this
potential
final match of this winter's finals joy
fury down two games
round set is tied eats the counter hit
and he's going to go to the wall for
that mistake
pretty close to it no splat but pretty
close to it
oh pushing again look at this this oh my
gosh this transition here
from bin chan closing it out and now one
round away from
securing a spot in our grand finals and
this
is gonna be troublesome i feel like the
last time these last these guys played
uh joey fury actually took it i believe
the last time i played in icfc
oh here we go nice grab attempt this
time breaking out of it
and again it's crazy that we're thinking
about this like you know grand finals is
great at all but grand finals ain't [ __ ]
you still have the king of the hill
challenge at the very end you still have
the king of the hill
so basically this ain't even grand
finals this is still winner's side
this is the winner side of the the
bracket actually because both of these
guys are coming off a totality that's
all it is it's a formality
once again look at the spacing that ben
chang is playing and then all those
pokes has gotten them back into this
match
potentially that could have been a big
pun it could have been the round
oh he's swinging he's looking to fish
out for something here nice side step
attack
seconds left down back to the big
counter hit this is big you got to spin
the rage
guess for your life he breaks the oh my
god goes for the big mid and the down
four
joey fury's still alive on the winner's
side wow
it was interesting that he didn't go for
the rage are there you know especially
with time
going up against him but hey he was
still able to pull it off there with
that down for that was clutch
what did i talk about you have to make
ben chang antsy and this is making
this matchup a lot easier for joey fewer
oh big swings this is not a good
position for joy fury side step four
hits him on the ground
tries to delay it two one for the punish
delay jabs to try to keep him honest
goes for the power question looking for
something out of bin chang he doesn't
bite
goes for the low what a block tries to
interrupt gets the cow hit on the string
nice punish
he didn't believe in it but he believes
in it the second time
joey fury sent down to the loser's side
that means ben chang
is gonna secure himself that ride to
grand
finals uh takes it 3-0 versus joey fury
and like i was saying if i'm not
mistaken we might have to check
the icfc tapes but i'm pretty sure the
last time that these guys played each
other
joyfully took it and uh i think it was
because he might not have been playing
claudio but congratulations
grand final showing